oh
yes lil nose x released his first brand
new video
of 2021 today for montero call me by
your name and the video is
super queer and visually stunning in the
video
lilna's ex introduces us to the
fantasyland of montero which happens to
be his first name
a place where he is free to embrace his
a sign of sexuality times every time
that i speak the music video shows us
lil nos
x's alter egos with visuals inspired by
historical moments
and mythology like making it with an
alien version of himself
a marie antoinette inspired stoning
scene and a lap dance
with the devil
[Music]
[Music]
celebrities have started showing their
support online for the brand new music
video including ollie alexander
kailyn allen drag race winner aquaria
and demi lovato who posted to her
instagram story
i'm gagging this is so effing fire go up
penny
along with the music video lil nos ex
shared a powerful letter he wrote to his
14 year old self which in part said
i know we promised to never come out
publicly i know we promised to never be
that type of gay person i know we
promise to die with the secret
but this will open doors for many other
queer people to simply exist
the letter continued you see this is
very scary for me
people will be angry they will say i'm
pushing an agenda but the truth is
i am the agenda to make people stay the
out of other people's lives and stop
dictating who they should be
sending you love from the future and
this is why i am a huge
little nas x fan i love his honesty and
i love what he's doing for the queer
community
so what do you think of his brand new
video what did you think of his letter
to his 14 year old self
what would you tell your 14 year old
self let me know in the comments below
hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos